ce étonnant non
[Musique]
les yeux le seigneur a dit tu aimeras
ton prochain comme toi même
personnellement je préfère moi même et
j'ai horreur qu'on petit toit cependant
avec un peu d'entraînement nous pouvons
parvenir à aimer notre prochain presque
autant que moi même la meilleure façon
d'aimer notre prochain comme moi même
consiste à l'intégrer le plus
naturellement du monde à nos jeux les
plus humbles ainsi vais-je maintenant
jouer à colin maillard avec ce
sympathique aveugle échec car
l'aveuglent est le seul prochain qu'ils
soient toujours prêts à jouer à colin
maillard sans le moindre accessoire
regardez bien qui moi non pas vous prêt
prêt
celle aveugle non non
[Musique]
etonnant non